[Music]
be not elated at any excellence which is
not your own
if the horse in his elation were to say
i am beautiful
it could be endured but when you say in
your relation
i have a beautiful horse rest assured
that you are elated at something good
which belongs to a horse
what then is your own the use of
external
impressions therefore when you are in
harmony with nature in the use of
external impressions then be elated
for then it will be some good of your
own at which you will be elated
chapter 6 stresses a disjunction that
epictetus has already introduced
in the end caridian between that which
belongs to us
or is in our control and what
is external what is in in many respects
quite literally
none of our business certainly not our
affair
and so this example about a horse and we
can think of
all sorts of other things that we might
connect this with in our own time since
horses are not
such a feature of our everyday
experience i think for most of us
really drives this home he says be not
elated
at any excellence that
is not your own literally that belongs
to
something else so if the horse he says
you know if we hypothesize right the
horse could be proud
of its own beauty or of its own strength
or its own
you know winning the first prize at the
fair anything along those lines
if the horse in his elation were to say
i am beautiful
i am fine i am i am cologne right
then it could be endured we could put up
with that it would make sense
but he says when you say in your elation
i have a beautiful horse
rest assured that you're elated at
something good
which belongs to something else in this
case a horse
and how many things can we say this
about
you know you could run through the
entire listing
of things that are not really in our
control
that people tend to be excited about to
be proud about to want to brag about
to want everybody to notice them for
you know we could start with the body
you know some people
are born tall i was fortunate in that
respect
i didn't do anything to get born tall
it's not something that
i should actually be proud of as if i'd
achieved something i suppose if i did
exercises which made me tall
that that could be the case other people
are really
into their clothing you know people can
spend an
awful lot of time researching what the
fashions are and they they actually can
identify
something where i'm totally deficient
they can identify if this person is
wearing that shirt or that handbag or
this accessory
and they care about that sort of thing
but
that's totally when we say that's not
you
we don't just mean that that's not your
style it's not you
you can strip away all of that as
happens to people
in disasters or say when they go to
prison or when they switch into their
pajamas
for going to sleep at night or their
their swimwear
um and you know think about the
possessions that we
we own that people are so proud of oh
i've got a great
car i've got a great computer i've got a
beautiful house
that's great but it's the house that's
beautiful it's not
you that is in any way beautiful for
owning a beautiful house
you're not a better person in any
respect because you have
nice things this is a common tendency
though you see this
in all societies pretty much that there
are some possessions that
are you know marking their possessors
apart
from other people as somehow being
better than them
we can say the same thing about power
and fame and political office
i often observe when when people you
know i get recognized now because of the
videos
i'll say well you know there's famous
famous and then there's
youtube famous so you don't want to get
too worked up about
that sort of thing now imagine what it's
like for people whose
faces are on billboards and
who then you know walk around oh that
billboard even that
might be an image of your face but it's
not
you the mere fact that that some
advertising agency thought that your
face ought to be up there
really not that that big of a deal when
you when you think about it
being mentioned in books having a
wikipedia
article devoted to you which actually
could be a bad thing given the way that
wikipedia
sometimes works and the way the editing
process
uh gets carried out we could go on and
on
and on holding a political office
is not necessarily a sign that you're
equipped for the office
or that you're the best person for the
job as compared to your competitors or
even that you have a good
you know head or heart so to be elated
to be
worked up to be excited to be proud of
things that don't really belong to you
that's a problem why
he says well what is your own
and notice that he only talks about one
of the things that is
our own one of the things that does in
fact belong to us but it's a really
central one
and this is what he calls the
use of external impressions
or the crisis the that's the word for
using
also means the way in which we use
things and then external impressions or
appearances
are fontasia so what really is
our own the ways in which we respond to
what is coming in from the outside how
do we
use them do we use them well do we use
them
poorly do we respond to them in a
thoughtful way
that could be you know at least to some
degree rational
or do we immediately jump to all sorts
of conclusions and then
you know get angry get upset get anxious
all of these are our possibilities for
use and epictetus will stress
that although external things themselves
are indifferent
our use of them is not our use of them
is very important
our relationships with other people that
is a matter of
fantasia which then we can use
as well fontasia can also be
not necessarily external but but inside
of ourselves how do we think about our
own selves that is indeed up to
us how do we make use of the ideas that
we've taken in
and internalized and made our own
how do we make use of stoic philosophy
all of that is a matter
of what is really in our power and if we
want to feel
proud about anything that's what we
should feel
proud about so he says therefore
when you are in harmony with nature in
the use of
external impressions then be elated
don't be elated don't think a lot of
yourself
because you have a great house think a
lot of yourself
if you actually can use that great house
in a
proper way so that you're not just
wasting that that wonderful resource
that's been given to you
likewise if somebody or a lot of people
think well enough of you to entrust you
with political office
or you know to be in a position of
responsibility in some institution
then make use of that and make the
proper use
and then you've got something to be
proud of let you know
if if you've got a great body that's
great but
what about your what about your mind
what about your soul
that's what you want to attend to so
this is uh some some classic
you know stoic uh advice he's saying
then it will be some good of your own
what really belongs to you
at which you will be elated if you're
going to be
proud if you're going to be elated if
you're going to be
worked up about something let it be the
things that really do
in fact fall within your purview
just as on a voyage when your ship has
anchored if you should go on shore to
get fresh water you may pick up a small
shellfish or little bulb on the way but
you have to keep your attention fixed on
the ship
and turn about frequently for fear
unless the captain should call
and if he calls you must give up all
these things if you would escape being
thrown on board
all tied up like the sheep so it is
also in life if there be given you
instead of a little bulb and a small
shellfish a little wife and child there
will be no objection to that
only if the captain calls give up
all these things and run to the ship
without even turning around to look back
and if you are an old man never even get
very far away from the ship for fear
that when he calls you may be missing
what we have here in chapter 7 is a very
interesting
little metaphor or if you like a story
an allegory about how we ought to
approach life and it's telling us a
little bit about the shortness of life
and about how contingent everything is
and how we
ought to comport ourselves so he says
just as on a voyage when your ship has
been anchored right
so for us that's probably not something
quite so easy to relate to
we might think about when you're at the
airport and you're waiting for your
connecting flight
or when you're on a road trip and you've
parked
and you're waiting or you know taking a
bus or a train or anything like that
he says you should go if you should go
on shore to get fresh water
you may pick up some items right you can
wander around a bit you can
you can find some things that catch your
fancy that's okay
nothing wrong with that he says a small
small shellfish or a little bulb right
you pick some raw
onions on the way but you have to keep
your attention
fixed on the ship and turn about
frequently
for fear less the captain should call
so you don't want to wander off too far
and
you know you might actually say at this
point well wait a second
if this is a metaphor about life and how
we ought to be living it
wouldn't it be nicer if once they let us
go ashore
we never come back why should we listen
to the captain well because
as we're going to see a little bit later
on when you get called back
you don't really have a choice about it
death
when it comes is going to find you
either prepared for it
or not prepared for it so he goes on and
he says
when the captain calls you must give up
all these things
if you would escape being thrown on
board and all tied up like the sheep
the sheep or other livestock don't
really want to travel
and so what they do is they tie them up
and then they just throw them on board
so you can approach your life
and its end and the things that fill
your life
all these considerations you can do that
in a thoughtful way
in a way that's going to allow you to be
prepared for when you do meet your end
or you're going to be dragged
essentially as we say kicking and
screaming
and get thrown on the same deck anyway
if you're going to die
at a particular time from a particular
reason and there's there's a whole
discussion that could be had about
stoics and fate
but we don't need to go into that here
but if you're going to die
what will matter at that point is
whether you're ready for it or not
whether you have a good death or not
so we do pick up a lot of things along
the way
all you need to do in order to see that
is go into somebody's automobile
and see all the the stuff that's
accumulated in it
or look at a house you know if somebody
owns a house
go down in their basement or wherever
else they're storing all the stuff that
they haven't figured out what to do with
it look at their junk drawer right
and you're usually going to find there's
a lot of things that have not been taken
care of and are not in order
and you know many people die it's not so
much about possessions although perhaps
they die without a will
and their heirs have to fight over
things but a lot of people die
and they haven't really attended to
their relationships
they haven't adequately looked at
what's going on in in all their
different connections with other people
with their family
with their friends with their neighbors
with with other people that they're
involved with
they avoid thinking about these sorts of
things because they would rather focus
on the living
than on what's going to happen
eventually but you know do you
this is worth considering do you want to
reach the end
having all sorts of unfinished business
that you're now
not going to have the time for you're
going to have to drop the little bulb
you're going to have to drop the little
shellfish that you've picked up you're
gonna have to drop
all the other stuff and when you drop it
are you going to break it
is it going to be lost is it going to be
in bad condition
that's well worth considering so he goes
on
and he says so it is also in life
if there be given you instead of a
little bulb and a small
shellfish a little wife and child there
will be no objection to that
that everybody's fine with with being
given things only
if the captain calls give up all these
things
and run to the ship without even turning
around to look back
if they're in good condition they'll
they'll do fine
you're going to have to leave them
behind no matter what
so you know you have to cultivate a
certain
level you might say or attitude at least
of or at least inclination or wish for
detachment because sooner or later
everything that you have
will in fact not be taken away from you
but as he says later on
be given back so he says if you're an
old man
never even get very far away from the
ship for fear that when he calls
you may be missing so particularly when
we're old and epictetus you know
at the time that he's teaching describes
himself
as an older man
when we're old we have to think about
this even more
because our time ironically the longer
we live
the shorter our time gets right we have
a much longer stretch behind us
the young have much much more time ahead
of them
even though they they have very little
time behind them
so this is a good metaphor it can help
us to
if we think about it and reflect upon it
it can help us to
structure our life in ways that are
going to be helpful for us
and allow us to approach things that we
normally
think of as calamities like death with a
certain measure of tranquility
do not seek to have everything that
happens happen
as you wish but wish for everything to
happen as it actually does happen
and your life will be serene
chapter eight is one of the shortest
chapters in epictetus's end caridian
it is in fact one of those dogmata or
you know
sayings or or ways of thinking about
things
that you want to have ready at hand when
you encounter
difficulties i mean you could look it up
in the book but it's so short that you
could easily
memorize it and and then have it
available as a resource so don't seek to
have everything that happens
happen as you wish the greek for that is
fella you know what you
want things to be what what your will
is so you know if you're drinking coffee
perhaps the coffee
got cold while you're you know waiting
to
to have a chance to drink it well
you'd like for it to be warm but in
order to do that you've got to go warm
it up right it's not going to
magically do that by itself but you know
coffee being cold is not really that big
of a
a deal in the the grand scheme of things
is it so
don't seek to have everything that
happens happen as you wish
but here's where reversal takes place
and this is something that we we can in
fact do
wish for everything to happen as it
actually
does happen and your life will be
serene you will actually be
content you will be happy so
you might say this is telling you hey
you should just whatever happens just
suck it up and get used to it that's not
actually willing that things be the way
they are
that's not an attitude of you might say
detachment
and letting things be that's actually
being resentful that things aren't the
way that you want them to be
but realizing that you can't force them
into the mold
of your own wish will desire however you
want to put it
so it's not a reactive attitude it's
rather
a acceptance of things
as they are and going beyond mere
acceptance and willing that things be
the way they are it's an
affirmation so we can do this
in a lot of respects one way that he
doesn't talk about here but i think can
be quite helpful
is you know you could you've got the
coffee and you say oh the coffee's
gotten cold
well cold coffee is you know pretty good
sometimes we like iced coffee it's not
quite iced coffee at this point but
it's on its way and you know i maybe
i may not be tasting exactly the flavors
that i i like so much in hot coffee but
you know there's also flavors that when
the coffee cools you taste
in a different way and i kind of like
those as well now not everything can be
so easily worked on upon that way so
that we
find the good side and everything but
we can realize that things work the way
that they do
um because that's the way the world
is is arranged that's the way that the
world
is set up so for example when we
apply for a job and you know we get
pretty far along you know nowadays you
fill things out online
and then they call you back and then
maybe they skype with you
and then maybe they say why don't you
come in and let's let's have an
interview
and you get there and you find out well
there's you know five other candidates
being considered
and we'll get back to you and then you
know a week later you get that call
saying well
we've offered the job to somebody else
that's very upsetting
and it's very easy and i'm speaking from
experience here
when you do apply for a job to already
engage in all sorts of imaginings that's
what
epictetus calls fontasia appearances
right
the appearance is i'm going to get this
job and then all the intellectual
you know motor work start running and
your emotions start getting involved you
start thinking
oh i wonder if my office is going to be
nice and
i'm going to have some great
responsibilities to deal with because
that's what they talked about
this will be an opportunity for me to
grow and and you get you start to get
quite excited
and anticipate having the job and then
you are disappointed
it doesn't go according to your wish
your will you have a choice at that
point
you can maintain your will and say
the world should revolve around my
wishes
my desires and somehow conform itself to
them
and if it doesn't do so that's because
it's a bad
world or you can realize that
if there is any badness involved it's
actually
in your own viewpoint on things
that you somehow think that everything
else should turn around you
i mean consider this as well does
everybody else
think the world should turn around them
could we possibly accommodate a world in
which
the world as a whole and all of its
processes had to orient itself around
every single person
it would be a a complete chaos wouldn't
it
because sometimes even our own desires
we're not
we're not fully coherent in what it is
that we want our own desires are kind of
a chaos
and contradiction or to use epictetus's
constant term for this
a battle a conflict within us so
if we decide instead to
wish for things to be the way that they
actually are
we will free ourselves up to
be happy we won't be affected by
outside circumstances disappointing us
by
them contravening what it is that we
wish because we will have changed
what it is that we wish for
disease is an impediment to the body but
not to the moral purpose
unless that consents lameness is an
impediment to the leg
but not to the moral purpose and say
this to yourself at each thing that
befalls you
for you will find the thing to be an
impediment to something else
but not to yourself
here in chapter 9 epictetus is setting
out the relationship
between what's really at our core the
pro-irasis
what's being translated here is moral
purpose also translated quite frequently
as faculty of choice all of that on the
one hand
and matters that we tend to
have a dread of we we view negatively
like disease or as as we've talked about
in other places
death lameness he talks about as well
and anything else that that we might
consider to be bad for us so poverty
people not liking us being forced to do
things that we
we don't enjoy being placed in in
situations of temptation
and he says all of these
aren't really impediments to
ourselves in what we really are they are
impediments to other things so he has
the example here of disease disease
is indeed an impediment to the body
nobody is suggesting
that disease is not a bad thing for the
body
that it doesn't keep the body from being
able to do
what it what it you know desires to do
or
or ought to do or its function would
extend to it doing
so you know for example if you have
heart disease your heart is
is being affected and that doesn't just
affect your heart it's gonna affect the
rest of your body
if you have um you know an allergy to
eating certain kinds of food
you know any of you have experienced
that know what that is like
and we could go on and on and on right
you have a fever you can't really
effectively work and sometimes can't
even think properly right you just have
to lay in bed
until the fever breaks so disease really
does
impede the body poverty does
really interfere with you going on a
vacation
people not wanting to hang out with you
does interfere with you having a party
and
inviting everybody over but
here's where the the key distinction
lies
is that interfering with or impeding
you and the answer is no because
what you really are is not just
your body or your possessions or your
online presence
or your uh capacity to
have a big blowout bash or anything like
that
what you are is what epictetus is
calling here moral purpose you're
pro-irasis right so he says that disease
is not
an impediment to the pro-irasis and
here's an
important proviso unless
you yourself
consent to it as he says here unless
it consents to it unless it chooses
what is doing the choosing the
pro-iracist that's you
you are a thing which can choose
you have a reflexivity to yourself
you can make choices about your own
choices
you are capable of self-determination
and that's what makes the whole stoic
philosophy itself
have any point to it whatsoever if you
were just a robot or you were just
you know living a purely animalistic
existence where you're just responding
on the basis of your biology and what
cues you've learned from your
environment
and perhaps some level of culture or
something like that
but you had no real capacity for choice
and for self-determination
there wouldn't be any point whatsoever
in stoic philosophy
or really in any moral philosophy
why is that well because
you have the capacity to choose for
yourself
you can in fact choose the path that
says
you're right disease is an impediment to
my body but it's not an impediment to me
as such just because i'm sick i don't
have to be a jerk to everybody
i don't have to lay around in bed and
moan and groan
and say oh woe is me
life is terrible now right you can say
i'm sick and i understand that i'm sick
i'd rather
not be sick than be sick but that
doesn't keep me from
thinking that doesn't keep me from being
able to choose
it may make it more difficult for me i
may be more irritable
or depressed or something like that when
i'm physically sick
but i i can choose the other possibility
is you do let it get you down you do let
it affect you
and if you do that that's because you're
using that
very free faculty of choice you are
freely using it and letting something
else determine it
you're letting something else make the
decision for you
you are making a decision to allow
something else to be decisive
so it doesn't have to be an impediment
to you
he goes on and he says
lameness is an impediment to the leg but
not to the moral purpose this is
something epictetus knew firsthand
because his
owner when he was a slave damaged his
leg
in such a way that he was lame
thereafter he never fully recovered
i know what that's like myself because
several years back and still hasn't been
fixed
i tore some ligaments in in one of my
knees
and fortunately you can't really tell
when i walk but
i certainly feel it if i walk very far
and there's you know unless i actually
get the operation there's not much to be
done about it
but that doesn't have to keep me or in
this case epictetus
from choosing freely from thinking about
the way
uh one's life is going from you know
looking at our desires and aversions and
deciding for ourselves
do we want to keep these desires and
aversions are they rational
or do we need to rework them the moral
purpose the
pro-racist is something that uh can can
function
and does function independently of
circumstances like that
so he goes on and he says say this to
yourself
at each thing that befalls you
everything that happens to you
you will find the thing to be an
impediment to something else
but not to yourself let's use the
example of online presence
right you get onto social media and you
say
wow you know i've read about these
people who
you know have all these these great
interactions with other people
i'm gonna do that i'm gonna get on
facebook or twitter or
you know whatever reddit and you get on
and nobody's paying attention to you
and it takes a while before things build
as they call it organically
um and you never really have the
you know 5 000 friend count that you see
other people have
well that's not an impediment to
anything that really matters
that certainly is an impediment to
having perhaps an
online event where you invite everybody
to talk about stoicism
but it's not an impediment to you
practicing stoicism
is it it's not an impediment to you
deciding hey am i going to read this
book
or am i not going to read this book am i
going to bring these
these dogmata these ideas to to bear
upon my life or am i just going to
putter around kind of in a dilettante
sort of way all of that is up to you all
of that is within
your realm of choice all of that is
what you are your online presence is not
you even though you may have picked out
a clever avatar and have all sorts of
selfies in it
and have written you know poured out
your heart into
posts or something like that it's still
not you it's something that you don't
have
control over and all sorts of things can
impede it
but none of those things have to
actually impede you
in your faculty of choice
you